la rave première
octobre 1972 une paire de fesses en
flammes paris image insolite
actuellement l'âge d'un solide s'il en
fût sur les murs de la capitale pour
annoncer son prochain spectacle à
l'olympia michel polnareff sa fiche et
provoque un ticket planète grandes
choses
sur la fiche le chanteur et dodo
travestie par paco rabanne et avec le
postérieur à l'air étant un bloc besoin
d'une bonne petite faith et six mille
affiches sont placardées un peu partout
dans la capitale
scandale dans une france encore très
puritaine ce coup marketing ne passe pas
la polémique enfle michel polnareff
tente de se défendre si les gens et si
l'on assiste à une provocation c'est que
eux sont en retard jeu pendant je
prenais un certain plaisir d y aura à
prouver que les 60 en retard non pas du
tout il ya déjà que c'est il ya déjà que
ça que ça amuse beaucoup la majorité
henri je suis bien content
et de toute façon je suis content de
voir que le public a tout du mourre que
les autorités l'affiché parfois censuré
dans la rue un carré blanc devant les
fesses mais pour certains français au
contraire ce portrait n'a rien de
provocant qu'à l'époque dans les mags a
des goûts des gens nus à lens
et les peuples et polnareff est tout à
fait trop autour il ya près du mans
tâche étant occupé la raison est un gars
très sympa moi j'aime beaucoup deux mois
plus tard en décembre 1972 la sphère des
fêtes de polnareff prend encore plus
d'ampleur le chanteur est convoqué
devant la justice motif attentat à la
pudeur je crois que tout le monde est
restée très embêté voilà à tellement les
traits plus on est très embêté dans
cette histoire parce que je crois que
disons que c'est ces gens sont obligés
de faire ce qu'ils estiment être leur
métier et que je trouve dommage
simplement que cette affaire soit allé
aussi loin parce que c'était un canular
et je crois que tout le monde est obligé
renan de jouer un rôle très belle mais
très dommage verdict soixante mille
francs d'amendé soit un peu plus de 9000
euros pour l'artiste
quelques mois plus tard le chanteur
jouera une nouvelle fois les
provocateurs sur la fiche de son nouveau
spectacle terminé les fesses pour michel
polnareff il est de face nu avec pour
seul accessoire son célèbre chapeau
prouvant son sexe
[Musique]